This is a download from BBC Learning English.
To find out more, visit our website.
6 Minute English
From BBC Learning English
Hello, this is 6 Minute English from BBC Learning English.
I'm Neil.
And I'm Rob.
Fancy a game of food connections, Rob.
So I'll name a place and you say the first food that comes to mind.
Ready?
Yeah, sure, let's go.
Italy.
Pizza or Lissagna.
New York?
Hot dogs, of course, or maybe bagels.
Now, how about Cornwall from the UK?
Oh, right. If it's Cornwall, it must be the famous Cornish Pasty, right?
That's right.
Cornwall, the region which forms the southwestern tip of Britain,
is as famous for its pasties as New Yorkers for hot dogs.
In this programme, we'll be finding out all about Cornish pasties
and we'll hear how it's gone from humble beginnings
to become a symbol of Cornish identity
and spread around the world to Jamaica, Argentina and Brazil.
But what exactly is a pasty, Neil?
Somewhere between a pie and a sandwich, right?
A piece of pastry which is turned over and crimped along the side
to make two corners.
And filled with different ingredients,
which brings me to my quiz question for today, Rob.
What is the traditional filling in an authentic Cornish Pasty?
Is it a chicken avocado and bry, b, beef potato and turnip,
or c, pork, onion and chorizo?
Well, chorizo is Spanish, isn't it?
An avocado with bry doesn't sound traditionally Cornish,
so I'll say b, beef potato and turnip.
Okay, Rob, we'll find out later if you were right.
What's for sure is that the Cornish Pasty has had a long history
as BBC Radio 4's The Food Programme discovered.
They spoke to Dr. Polly Russell, a public life curator at the British Library.
Here she is reading from one of the earliest mentions of pasties
from the late 17th century.
There's a lovely bit here where he's describing
what a housewife in Hertfordshire does,
and he's talking about her way to make pork pies and pork pasties.
Pies may be made and baked, either raised in paste,
earth and pans or imputed dishes, or in the shape of a turnover,
two-corned pasties.
So that's a very early reference to a pastie in the shape,
I think, that we know it, but also being made specifically for laborers
to be feeding laborers on a farm at harvest time.
So the earliest pasties were made in pewter dishes,
a traditional cooking plate made of a silver coloured metal called pewter.
And they were eaten by agricultural laborers, workers doing physical farmwork during harvest time,
the weeks in autumn when crops like wheat are cut and collected from the fields.
But it wasn't only farmers and laborers who ate pasties.
As well as its farms and fishing,
Cornel was famous for tin mines, as Ruth Huxley of the Cornish Pasties Association explains.
Pasties would have been eaten by lots of people who went to work,
but it just worked perfectly down mines and Cornel became the world capital of mining.
And so lots of pasties were made, lots of pasties were eaten,
and then that mining community went all over the world and took the pasties with them.
Pasties were eaten by hungry workers involved in the mining industry,
digging up materials such as coal or metals like gold or in Cornwall tin from the ground.
So far we've been talking about Cornel, but you said the Cornish pastie has spread around the
world, Neil. How did that happen? Well, that's connected to the tin miners we just talked about.
Here's Pauli Russell again. This is replicated not just in Mexico, but with migrants moving to
America, to Minnesota, to Canada, to Australia. So anyone who travels to many of those places now
will see foods which are incredibly reminiscent and familiar and just like Cornish pasties.
In the 19th century, many Cornish tin miners emigrated moving abroad to start a better life.
Their pasties recipes were replicated or copied exactly in the new places where they landed
from America to Australia. And that's why in many places around the world, you can find food which
is reminiscent of pasties, meaning it reminds you of something similar. In this case, the original
Cornish pastie with its traditional filling of, what was your quiz question again, Neil?
Ah, yes. I asked you what the traditional Cornish pastie filling was. You said.
I said B, beef potato and turnip. And you were right. Kess Lawena Robb,
that's Cornish for congratulations. Heb Grev, Neil, that's no problem.
In fact, those other fillings, Churrisso, avocado and bry, really did feature in pasties
entered for this year's annual world pastie championships held in Cornwall every spring.
Other pastie inspired ideas include Argentinian, Chimichuri and Panadas and spicy Jamaican patties.
So the pastie is still going strong both in Cornwall and around the world.
Today we've been discussing Cornish pasties, a kind of filled pastry from the southwest of England,
originally made in pewter dishes, that's a silver-colored metal dish. Pasties were eaten by agricultural
labourers, farm workers bringing in the autumn harvest, the time when crops are cut and collected
from the fields, and also by workers in the tin mining industry, digging up metals like tin
from underground. Later, when these miners emigrated to new lands, pasties were replicated,
cooked again in the same way. In fact, Cornish miners moved to so many new countries that today,
almost every corner of the world has food reminiscent of or reminding you of the original Cornish
pastie. That's all for today. Join us again soon for more topical discussion and vocabulary on
6 Minute English. Goodbye for now. Bye bye.